thank you don't look old enough to
become a grandfather this year oh I I
thank you for saying that I'm I'm I'm
old enough I just trust me let's not
talk numbers I've never been good at
numbers but uh but we're very we're very
much looking forward to that so excite
what kind of grand Papa are you going to
be and you have you picked out your
grandpa named papi talking a lot about
that I think um I think I'm just gonna
let the kid kind of come up with it
himself so if your grandson or daughter
says that they want to call you Tony
it's gonna be like cool for just me Tony
bring me my milk I'd prefer sir Tony but
I'm sure so happy for you what a time in
your life we've got another whole season
to come and and I know you don't know
anything but can you tell me something
no no about season four no I told me
that she heard they're gonna murder me
so it's gonna just be Alex net have not
heard that but she's always been bucking
to be number one on the call sheet that
I know she's just an insatiable you know
ego egomaniac you've already won an Emmy
for this role so what would it mean to
win tonight well I I don't know I feel
like just being here is kind of a win in
itself and you know as much as I would
love to win I don't want people to start
to you know roll their eyes and start to
resent the fact that I have I think I do
have a decent number of Screen Actors
Guild Awards already and so one one does
not want to appear greedy
you gotta keep that eat humble humble
Tony humble Tony twenty20 you know it
would be great but like also I'm good
you don't be to Beyonce with it you know
right that's right but it but if that
happens you know I will
obnoxiously jump up and down like stick
it in everyone's face say it's about
time yeah I told you it was me all along
hey I'm gonna use okay up there tonight
you'd be like you know what I am the
biggest star in this room thank you very
much De Niro who can I can I can I steal
this moment exactly congratulations man
see you backstage awesome
[Music]